de plus en plus le bois s'invite dans
nos villes par le passé il fut un
élément central de la construction
peuchère rapidement mis en oeuvre
il a traversé les époques plus
solidement que la pierre ou le faire
nous sommes à orléans
nous y rencontrons eric directeur darbo
centre l'association
interprofessionnelle de la filière bois
en région centre dans ce quartier qui
associe patrimoine et modernité
le bois est l'élément clé avant on avait
tendance à faire des croix pour
s'assurer que ça fonctionne bien que ça
ne tombe pas maintenant on a des
systèmes qui sont mis en place et qui
sont vraiment optimisé donc on optimise
aussi la quantité de bois qu'on utilise
et en optimisent aussi la quantité de
bois qu'on prélève dans la forêt la
forêt une ressource qui couvre un quart
de notre paysage régional et répondent
en partie aux besoins de la construction
bois un des atouts de ce matériau sa
qualités d'isolant thermique ici à
orléans la source
un bailleur social expérimente son pari
réduire la facture énergétique des
locataires frédéric et eric échanges sur
le bilan énergétique de ces maisons
dites passives premier bilan najdi
qu'aujourd'hui sur cette opération est
plutôt positif
car quand nous comparons les relevés de
consommation des occupants sur environ
trois logements sur cinq
on est bien en dessous des objectifs
passif un projet de maison passive comme
celle là ça se prépare longtemps à
l'avancé et dans un certain nombre de
cas ça reste quand même assez
expérimental alors nous on est surtout
intervenue pour accompagner l'entreprise
parce que c'était aussi sa première
expérience de maisons passives et donc
on était là pour l'aider à faire les
bons choix avec l'architecte
deux chiffres clés concernant les
bâtiments basse consommation 20% plus
cher à la construction mais 60 %
d'économies sur la facture énergétique
ainsi de 2006 à 2012 la part de
construction bois en région centre val
de loire et passer de cinq à 13 % soit
parents 650 construction et autant
d'extension mais la construction bois
intéresse aussi les collectivités la
halle bois au lycée gaudier brzeska de
saint-jean-de-braye en est un exemple
si les matériaux sont mixte béton acier
c'est le bois qui domine il permet
d'obtenir de grands volumineux
nécessaires aux 4000 m² répartis en
salles de cours et ateliers dont une
vraiment une multitude de matériaux à
base de bois qui font que on arrive à
faire des constructions bois extrêmement
performante et cette performance qui
donne finalement cette liberté aux
architectes et ensuite cette qualité de
vie qu'on peut avoir dans les bâtiments
bois la halle symbole d'une démarche
durable a pour vocation d'abriter les
formations de la filière bois dont un
nouveau cursus d'enseignement supérieur
il ya deux filières dans la construction
la filière humide traditionnel la
maçonnerie et puis ce qu'on appelle la
filière sèche la filière construction
bois alors elle est très développée par
exemple dans les pays anglo saxons dans
le nord de l'europe en grande bretagne
aux états unis en france c'est beaucoup
plus émergents nous étions avec la corse
les deux seules régions de france qu'il
n'avait pas de formation supérieure dans
la construction bois à savoir le bts
systèmes constructifs bois et habitat la
filière bois en région centre val de
loire est en pleine ascension le
développement d'une exploitation
cohérente de nos forêts locales et
l'organisation de circuits courts
permettront une économie locale
responsable plus forte la forêt cultivée
est un atout écologique économique et
gage d'un paysage forestier préserver